hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast through the looking-glass and
what amino acids found they're presented
by Kirsty Pinkman reader and analytical
chemistry Sheriff chemistry graduate
school Department of Chemistry
University of York I'm Alexis Krause of
lab routes and I will be your moderator
for today's events we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab routes Labatt's is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
fictional events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left ear
screen and type your questions into the
drop-down box that appears on the screen
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Pinkman I will now turn the presentation
over to her thank you very much and so I
wanted to give you a bit of an insight
into the wonderful kind of world of
analytical chemistry meshing with
archaeological and earth science that's
been my experience over the last few
years and so please invite you to come
through the looking glass with me to
find out what amino acids fiber so amino
acids are the basic building blocks of
proteins and of course they're
chemically very interesting because in
life amino exist' acids exist in two non
super imposable forms mirror images of
each other just like left and right
hands because of that chiral center that
they they all have a part from glycine
now are almost all organisms synthesize
amino acids in the left-handed form but
actually this artificial dominance of
the one form is thermodynamically
unstable and so once an organism dies or
there's no more tissue turnover this
spontaneous reaction customization
occurs until you get an equal amount of
left-handed and right-handed amino acids
so you can think of it as the
left-handed amino acids being living
amino acid and the right-handed the
dextro amino acid being the dead acid
obviously that's not what they stand for
but that's a good reminder of what you
would expect to see and once an organism
dies so at time zero we would measure
what we call a DL value so that's just
the number of D amino acids over the
number of elements and and that would
give you a value of zero because all
your you know acids would be in the
left-handed form but when the organism
dies then this a number of D amino acids
gradually increases until you get to
that equilibrium point where you have an
equal amount of left-handed and
right-handed amino acids over time so
you can use this these proportions of
left-handed and right-handed amino acids
for a range of different studies now I'm
particularly interested in the kinetics
of protein breakdown and it's also very
important
looking at the biological production of
D amino acids particularly from
bacterial amino acids and and this has
led me into two particular pathways
trying to understand chronology your
timing and trying to understand past
environments and now analyzing fossil
and sub fossil samples is really
interesting to me as an analytical
chemist because these samples are
they're very dirty full of contamination
the the analyte of interest is present
in incredibly low concentrations there's
all this other stuff that you have to
worry about so analytically they're
incredibly challenging but I think it's
really important to remember that we
shouldn't just be analyzing fossils with
our fancy machines just because we want
to it's very important to make sure that
we are providing data to those people
who have charge of their samples and
is useful for their research questions
it's useful in questions of archaeology
or air science and and I kind of showed
this through this very old far side
cartoon by Gary Larson he these cavemen
have gone to all the trouble of building
this fancy microscope and they stick
their mammoths underneath it and
actually all they can say is it's a
mammoth well they knew that they didn't
need to pop there they didn't need to
use these fancy method of analysis to
work out some Ameth and and so in my
studies what I'm trying to do is is
really push the analytical methods
forward by analyzing these complex
samples but do it in a way that answers
relevant questions to the collaborators
so I've got three case studies which I'm
hoping at this this shows that I want to
talk about in this talk so the first is
looking at the dating work that we've
been doing marking time at snail's pace
the next is extending that dating work
but going into the realms that we never
envisaged but I building a better rectum
er and the last is to look at a
gradation in general through the fading
star project so marking time at snail's
pace
and now the time periods that we're in
at the moment is called the quaternary
time period and it's characterized by
these big swings and climate from very
warm stages that we have today circled
in interglacials
to very cold stages and the impact this
has on the on the globe and in
particular particular regions of the
globe is immense and so the top image
you can see and top right hand corner
and is an artist's impression of trowel
Square in London 125,000 years ago when
we have a warm stage and we have
underneath those buildings are the
incredibly rich fossiliferous remains of
things like elephants rhinoceroses even
hippos wallowing alongside the banks of
the Thames and now in contrast when we
have these cold stages these glacial
periods we get ice sheets as far south
as London so clearly massive climate
change on a that that's experienced by
the flora and fauna at that time here
now to put our current climate in
perspective it's essential that we look
back at our past records to understand
what's happened but the big problem that
we have is that we have these very
detailed temperature records as
graph that you can see on your screens
and from the icicles and from the marine
cause but on land we only have these
snapshots of information and it's very
difficult to date those because they're
not part of us a long continuous
sequence now many of you will have heard
of radiocarbon dating and radiocarbon
dating is a fantastic method but it only
goes back to around 60,000 years that
doesn't even go halfway to the last time
it was this warm in Britain and and so
in order to make those links from the
pockets that we have on land to the big
global climate we have to have a dating
method now amino acid static Fe was
something that was developed in the
1960s in the 1970s and they recognized
that as an inherent part of any bio
mineral contains protein and if you look
in the top right hand corner you can see
this as an acid etched image where the
inorganic calcium carbonate has been
etched away and you just get these kind
of long sheathed like proteins that
actually form almost the scaffolding of
them in on itself um and some people
thought well actually this is really
interesting maybe what we could do is
measure the amount of L&D amino acids
from different materials particularly
shells and and those that have a greater
amount of D amino acids will be the
oldest and those that have a smaller
amount of amino acids will be the
youngest and we can date using this
method and they seem to work very well
for a few years but then some quite
strange results started to feed in um
and so by the time the 90s came around
this is the kind of thing that's being
said about it so um Milford Wolpaw he
was the leading paleoanthropologist he
was cited in science paper basically
saying amino acid dating is some kind of
joke and when my PhD supervisor was
chatting about getting into immune are
sedating at the person who's in charge
of of scientific dating in the UK named
heritage team leader said what on earth
do you want to work on that for it's the
last refuge of the desperate and so
coming into this as a PhD student
these weren't the most encouraging
things I can imagine to hear and but it
I came into thinking well can it work if
we use the right with
Tyrael and if we really understand the
chemistry underlying the maximization of
the actions so in the intervening years
there's been huge advances one of the
key things is the analytical technology
and so in the old days you were able to
analyze just one chiral amine acid pair
and aloe eyes to see the nicely seen
because it was very easy to chemically
separate using ion exchange
chromatography and but now we can
separate multiple amino acids using
reverse phase LC and we've just updated
this method to four as au HPLC messes
for being able to analyze various limb
samples what's great about this is that
these amino acids brass Mize at
different rates so it means we get
different information from each of those
and but it also flags up any
contamination if we're starting to see
unexpected changes in the in the extent
of rasterization against each other the
second advance has been in always
analyzing the free amino acid fraction
and the total mean is a fraction so our
proteins obviously exists as long chains
of amino acids but whether an amino acid
is is free or whether it's terminal or
whether it's internally bound will
affect the way that and so what we do is
we take two and independent sub samples
from each sample we break up one to give
us just the free main acids and then the
second we hydrolyze that we break up all
of those peptide bonds and we analyze a
tote to give us a measure of the total
amino acid fraction and that gives us to
effectively independent measures of age
on the same song should be highly
correlated the third thing which has
been absolutely essential to the use of
this method is isolating an inter
crystalline fraction of protein now in
most bio minerals like bone the protein
although it's an integral part of bio
mineral it sits between the crystallites
now the problem with that is that if
that means that the amino acids can leak
out into the environment they can
contamination could get into the system
they can also be affected by
rate-affecting factors in the
environment such as pH availability of
water metal catalysts and so on and so
if we analyze just these proteins then
there's very little chance of it telling
you something about the age of
now some really nice work done in the
1980s showed that actually in some bio
minerals there's a very small fraction
of protein that seems to be physically
entrapped within the crystal so-called
intra crystalline proteins now if we
analyze just these then there's a good
chance of it telling us about the age of
the sample so what we what we do is we
basically remove all of the protein that
isn't trapped within the crystal
we only analyze them to learn crystal
and to basically isolate a closed system
a protein that's breaking down
predictably so bibbidi-bobbidi do put it
together on what do we get we get what
we're calling IC PD or intra crystalline
protein decomposition so we've got a
range of ways in which we can share the
data one of the most useful mechanisms
we use to check what the quality of the
data is is by looking at those two
fractions that we pull from the same
sample and so along the x-axis here
you've got the extent of rasterization
in the free fraction and along the y
axis you've got the extent of Rasim
ization in the total fraction and what
we would expect to see is that young
samples fall towards the origin so low
levels of DL and older samples fall
towards the top right of the graph and
we would expect some full somewhere
along that line now if you use the old
method of dating thing looking at the
matrix proteins as well as those that
we're into crystalline what you see is
that a lot of samples do fall along that
line but an awful lot fall off to the
right hand side now these are evidence
that the material that we're analyzing
is not closed system however if we use
the bleaching method then we clean up
this data beautifully so by isolating
just the bleached fraction the intron
crystalline fraction we get this really
nice coherence between the free and the
total measurements so we can be more
confident in that the protein that we're
measuring is degrading predictably in a
closed system now as the work continued
we started to realize that actually we
need to concentrate not just on the
organic fraction of the shell but also
on the inorganic fraction so um most
shells exist in form of calcium
carbonates and and calcium carbonate can
assist in in two forms itself aragonite
and cows
site and also exist as battery that's
less biologically important now
aragonite is actually unstable over
giant geochemical it's right over
geological timescales and it can undergo
mineral diagenesis to form a more stable
calcite now in the european record we
have some very interesting little snails
called both iniya and this is the
athenaeus shell on your left-hand side
and it's little a particular in a
particular it's just the trapdoor the
snail uses to shut itself away inside
its shell now and the Bithynia shell is
made out of a Ragan ight but it's a perk
limp is made out of calcite so it gave
us a really useful mechanism to test and
the difference in the mineral
stabilities and what impact that had on
the rasterization so here the graph you
can see in your left hand corner is same
as we've been before the free
rasterization of in this case alanine
and the total rasterization of alanine
and again it's a total of estimation of
Adaline and what you can see is these
are all samples from one particular site
so we'd expect them to be all falling
around the same age around the same
point but what we can see is one clear
outline sample 13 when we analyze the
XRD of some one of the samples that's
sitting in the middle and you can see
that we've got clear Peaks related to
the Reaganite but no indication of kasih
in that's in that shale sample which is
expected but when we analyze FL 13 when
we analyze Santa 13 we can see in that
blue circle and that we've started to
see started to get some mineral
diagenesis at the rag nighter counseling
now obviously that's going to compromise
our closed system of protein even if
it's for a short period of time because
for some at some point in time that
crystal has changed from aragonite to
calcite
so if what we could do is analyze
something that's originally calcite
that's unlikely to undergo that mineral
diagenesis
then that will put us in a good position
hence we turned our attention to these
much smaller perkier so these are about
the size of a sesame seed but luckily
they're very prevalent in most in most
deposits and so we started to look at
these a real wide
times
so here on the y-axis you've got
maximization synthesis DL and on the
x-axis you've got thousand years ep so
this extends from time now all the way
back to three million years ago and what
you can see here I've just selected
three of the amino acids are
particularly helpful over this time
range you can see that the aspartic is
really really fast
reaches it equally but more quickly but
it gives us really great resolution over
those short time scales and something
like valine in the blue is rasa maizing
much more slowly so that's not you so
useful over the short time scales but it
tells us about there's longer time
scales getting us back to at least three
million years so we've been dating a
whole range of different sites initially
in the UK and now across Europe and
we're now dated over 150 sites and these
has given us critical data on the timing
of climate pulses back to three million
years and we've also been able to shed a
lot of light on some archaeological
questions and if you kind of go from the
right hand side of your graph down with
that you're going from the earliest
times all the way to the present day and
we've been able to kind of track the
archaeological technology development
with our wisdom ization and so here in
the oldest technology that present in
europe is made one technology and we can
see that coming in and then development
of these two technologies the plaque
tonin and the 'she lien and and then at
certain points about three hundred
thousand years ago we see this complete
flip to a different technology called
the Lavar technology now I'm not an
archaeologist but I understand that the
Devourer technologies is a technological
advance because for the same sort of
volume of flint it gives you a greater
cutting area and we see this real
dominance of this with our technology
art at this point in time we also see a
lack of humans getting into Britain in
that last interglacial which fits very
well with some of some of the ideas
about the channel formation and although
and and then we can track of humans and
all the way to the present day
and and and so a couple of years ago
amazing exhibition which our work was
and was a part of felt really privileged
to be involved in this and was put on at
the Natural History Museum and and in
London and when I went down there and to
be able to see our work kind of
emblazoned on the front of the building
that was a that was a real career
highlight definitely so of course now
that we think we've got closest and
protein in one time to bio mineral we
can look at a whole range of different
types of iron minerals and as Alice in
Wonderland would say somehow it seems to
fill my head with ideas we've been
looking at marine shells and we've been
now starting to work on enamel material
which is very interesting and we've been
doing a lot of work on corals which has
led us actually to look far more into
the biomineralization process to track
things like coral bleaching events and
and you know or even working with tiny
micro fossils such as foraminifera and I
just wanted to highlight a couple of the
studies that are most relevant from an
analytical point again so the work we
were doing on the dating led us three to
thinking about what other material we
could analyze and and one of one
calcitic material is excel now um we
were particularly interested in ostrich
egg shell and that's because its present
in huge proportions in some very early
human sites and particularly in the
African and Arabian material and you get
these incredible sequences of of ostrich
egg shell in cave deposits and we very
lucky to work with various researchers
working on the pinnacle point their cave
deposits down in South Africa and some
of the very earliest evidence of art and
is found on eggshell and it's thought so
it was uses water container so it's the
kind of breakthrough technology in terms
of enabling modern humans to travel so
it's a very interesting archaeological
artifact but of course within the
ostrich egg shell or the proteins that
we could potentially use to date him
what made ostrich egg shell even more
exciting was that the protein sequence
was known so the ordering of the amino
acids along that protein chain and so
that means that we can study the protein
breakdown not just using LC as
we have been full but also using mass
spec and and as an aside you can get
isotope data um on the XL to tell you
that PI decline it so it look like a
perfect and a perfect material to work
now when I said whether an amino acid
breathalyzers or not depends on where it
is in the chain there's a huge network
of reactions that that have to happen in
order for to result in a rat smallest
amino acid whether an amino acid is n
terminal if it's C terminal that makes a
big difference if it's internally bound
some amino acids can't rationalize at
all others can if it's free tends to go
relatively slowly but by being free it's
probably gone through peptide bond
hydrolysis which means it has to be in
terminal all of these affect the rates
of the reactions I said we wanted to
study this in more detail so we started
to look at ostrich egg shell because of
this known protein sequence dominated by
stew Thea calcine x 1/2 and these are C
type lectins which promote
polymerization
so this is the sequence on the right
hand side and so it's a quite short
peptide sequence and we were
particularly interested to start off
with in trying to work out how failing
Rises valine is a relatively simple
amino acid we thought it would probably
be quite simple to understand and so
what we did was we basically looked at
the whole protein but we also looked at
these short peptide fragments and
highlighted here in red and in orange so
what we call ed fig and and and the WN
SBW aw so we wanted to look at the whole
protein but was it the these peptides
and so we all just took a whole series
of artificial diagenesis experiments in
closed system environment within the
eggshell we then demineralize the
material and looked at what would happen
if it didn't have the mineral to protect
it we then looked at these very short
peptides to see what would happen in
those circumstances and then we track
these reactions using soft ionization
pretty much spec and and an SMS variety
of different methods moltov electrospray
fti CR and to basically look at those
mass shifts as the peptide breakdown
and an obviously lost that involved de
novia 16 of products and and we were
also tracking Nixon Tolleson
maximization using your first base LC
and so this meant for the first time we
were able to track that protein dar
Genesis in real time to try and
understand the mechanisms and the
kinetics actually so this is just one of
the examples this is our little
synthetic peptide advic and so this is
an undertow Spectras unheated and and
you can see the neckline here and then
as we heat it for a couple of hours
under as we see we start to see the that
peptide bond between the the d the
aspartic acid and the V the valine
breakdown and we and then we start to
see generation of that weak fragment
with the valine being n-terminal now
when we look at the extent of
atomization this fits really well so
this is the heating hours against the
extent of rasterization and we start to
see in a very slow increase in
rasterization probably because it's that
peptide bond hydrolysis that is the rate
determining step and then at that point
it can rise and then we start to see
this increase as time goes on now I like
this egg timer project because it
exemplifies how you should analyze
everything because um we ordered these
synthetic peptides in looked like a
clean aspect peak that they'd sent us
lcms peak and and then we analyzed it by
Bray LC and and what we found was that
half of the peptide that has been sent
to us was inevitable it was e AV w IG so
in half of the positions alanine had
been substituted for the acid jobless we
set up all the experiments they were
sitting in the ovens half of them done
already so I just said well let's just
analyze them anyway let's see what we
see and what I really love about this
gave us some fantastic data so actually
this is a perfect experiment in half the
places you have substitution of alanine
and you can see how that alanine valine
peptide bond is inherently more stable
and therefore that valine doesn't become
terminal and therefore doesn't
rationalize this quickly so it's a
beautiful experiment and
that that that we're writing up at noon
and so yeah so if things go wrong with
experiments don't worry it just analyzed
it and they could give you some really
some real diamonds of data we also
started to see enchain maximization
theory and this this was something that
had been hinted at in in our previous
work and by degrading this particular
peptide wns the WWE we were able to show
that the extent of customization
followed the patterns of aspartic which
frass misers in change rather than
alanine availing which can trust lies in
chain therefore showing that actually
the sarin was rasterizing within chain
now this is biologically very important
high levels of serine deal have been
implicated in and particularly
degenerative diseases like Alzheimer's
and Parkinson's and renal disease and so
one of the things we're doing is
expanding this work to try and
understand whether the rasterization is
a is a kind of is a product of what
we're seeing or or potentially if it's a
cause and either way can we use this as
a mechanism to track and to track the
mechanisms and that and the progress of
disease we then started look at the
archaeological material and we started
to go further and further back in time
as you look in the left hand graph this
is the sequence of strict accounting one
and and the and the and basically the
proportions of the spectra that
contained those particular you know
those those particular parts of the
sequence and what you can see as time
goes on as you go down the plot and you
can you get studio counseling preserved
for you know a good length of time by
150 thousand years you can still get the
whole sequence out in your mass spec but
what absolutely amazed us was how there
were particular portions of the peptide
was still sticking around by 1 million
years and even by 3.8 million years from
from the middle of Africa this is cycle
and they totally Tanzania we were
working with some very talented liquid
modelers in Sheffield in at Warwick and
they did some calculations to look at
the the binding energy to the calcite
surf
of these parts of the peptides and in
the domain with the strongest calculator
binding energy to the cows and so this
was the one that was selectively
preserved in our experiments over the
millionaire timescales it's a really
nice synergy so we we are very confident
these are original proteins a little bit
of work that helps us with that
confidence but it was the work that we
did using GC and ki Tov T to look at
some real volatile organic compounds
when we were preparing the external we
quite often had we've quite often had
and could smell particularly burnt
samples but when we were crushing them
or when we were when we were minimizing
them quite often got quite a strong
smell from them so there's obviously
some sort of volatile organics within
there so we have a great atmospheric
chemistry group here at the department
chemistry and and so I chatted them
about well what's the potential for us
to actually analyze this material and
some really talented guys now in our
workshop Chris Mortimer basically
prepared this inline sampler where we
could crush the material and then inject
it directly into the GC and and then
it's not very clear in this image but
there's an olfactory port here and in
the middle of the image and you can you
basically pop your nose in it and reject
the sample and then you breathe and
occasionally it spits hot also at you
which was rather alarming and but you
basically breathe it and then you rope
doesn't if you smell something you write
down the retention times and you write
down the smell and and then it goes
through into heat or perspective or
identification and I have to be honest
when I started describing this I was not
very descriptive Oh dusty musty frosty
turn up quite not in books and then I
started to get a bit more into it I've
got burnt dance summer day mushrooms
cucumber freek gums and probably the
inside thing quite a few of these BAC s
by the time I got to those two small oh
descriptive and terminology but what we
were in a way staggered to to find was
the still the presence within this
section of really very volatile
compounds particularly dominated by
these Styles now they
I exist in unless it's a closed system
we must have closed system preaching in
there which is which gives us real
confidence that our peptides are being
preserved and that's why we're getting
such great reproducibility in a rate and
reactions so up to this up to this point
well up to 2009 and all of this intra
crystalline and work was very
theoretical it was based on being able
to chemically bleach the material and
continue to bleach it and never be able
to remove all of protein but some really
nice advances in the imaging technology
and particularly by degrees at our group
and were able to show that these
actually exist in abalone shells and
there's really nice work showing that
that they these kind of faceted voids
exist within organic crystals and that
these faceted boys have extra carbon in
it and when you look at the size of them
they would you know our proteins would
fit really nicely in them so I think
this is probably the source of our and
crystalline material so this took us
into thinking a bit more about the by
mineralization processes and and so we
were working in collaboration with Leeds
and working with Sheffield and Cornell
and trying to grow crystals
incorporating new acids and so the lead
group growing the crystals then we were
analyzing them for how many amino acids
are operated in them and then people
were looking and to see whether they
were incorporated by single molecules or
as kind of clumps and and then doing
hardness studies and you can see the
change in morphologies you increase the
amino acid concentration as you go down
the page and the in the images of the
crystals formed and but what was really
interesting is that as you incorporate
more amino acids into your crystals so
if you look at the top right-hand graph
and the the the concentration of amino
acid incorporated on the x-axis and the
hardness of that material is on the
y-axis and you can see a really strong
increase
in the hardness as you incorporate more
amino acids up to a certain point what's
really interesting is that this takes it
from the kind of level of strength that
you would need to break an ionic bond
all the way up to the forces required to
break covalent bonds so it looks like
that enhance hardness which of course
nature has been using for millions of
years and the in heart hardness of that
composite material is determined by the
force that's required to cut the
covalent bonds in the incorporated amino
acid and hence why bio minerals are
intrinsically more stable than than
their pure inorganic counterparts so
it's taken us into some really
interesting worlds that I hadn't
anticipated so this egg timer project
and we were able to recover peptides
from archaeological eggshell for back to
3.8 years and why that's important side
of this study is that because peptides
contain evolutionary information because
they change over time and that means we
can track evolutionary changes in this
type of material over over those things
of time we were able to show the direct
evidence of sequence effect on
maximization and in chain
rationalization sharing and we came up
with this really nice way of dating our
samples which is exactly what we which
is what we'd intended the ground for in
beginning so these really exciting
serendipitous results and yeah are
really very rewarding okay so Alice at
some point through the looking-glass is
they've had quite enough in the subject
of aging thought so I wanted to put you
give you a little bit of an insight into
some of the other work that we've been
doing and particularly the fading star
shining like project that Kirstie hi is
the current nerd fellow and has been
working on so star car is a phenomenal
site very local actually it's in
Yorkshire and it's from around 11,000
years BC and it's called being called
the Stonehenge of the Mesolithic it's a
world-famous site because the
preservation at the site was phenomenal
particularly the organics so you get
these amazing hopping points jacketed
beads you get some of the earliest
evidence
between Europe these works wooden
platforms and and what's really striking
about this site is this huge number of
Red Deer and the headdresses and that
that appear at this site so this is
where the the skull of a Red Deer has
been cut at with sort of poles either
side almost maybe to put a thong through
and so it looks addresses maybe for
ambush hunting maybe for some kind of
wild parties and and and it's you know
as I said it's a world-famous site and
and it's even been immortalized by peg
reveal so it's these are pretty
impressive headdresses now the site was
discovered in the 1950s and as I said
one of the key features about it was
this fantastic preservation of organic
materials which obviously don't normally
survive to that length of time in the
1980s there was some evidence to suggest
that some of these organics had
deteriorated a bit but it was really in
the 2007 excavations that people became
more and more aware how how how in
danger some of these artifacts were
there were very few finds and the
antenna that was found was clean
flattened the bone that was found was
demineralized if you have a look and
just at the bottom right hand corner of
your picture there's a little animation
here which is basically the oh no there
wasn't animation there and which is
showing how flexible that's a piece of
bone but how flexible it was you could
actually move it up and down you
shouldn't be able to down boom
now there was very low pH measure of
this particular site and there was
evidence that a lowered water table was
due to a change in the drainage patterns
of this agricultural site and had led to
the water table kind of moving through
the archaeological deposits on a
seasonal basis this was causing
particular issues so the problem was
there was clearly an issue with the
organic materials but there was no data
on what kind of timeframe this could
have happened in how much longer the
organics remains could have survived at
Starke are whether anything could be
done to slow or stop the decay and and
this is a real problem
was a very big meeting with various
interested parties where actually we
couldn't really answer these questions
so I put together a project with York
archaeological trust funded by Newark to
basically say we need the hard data to
be able to answer these scientific
questions properly and so closely high
which creatures as a PhD student and she
set up a whole series of different types
of experiments lab based experiments and
burial experiments and comparative
archaeological tools now when the
critical things we had to work with in
this project was trying to work out what
methods of analysis we can use so we
wanted to be able to detect very low
levels of deterioration we need it the
methods to be minimally destructive and
for wider take up in the archaeological
community we wanted them to be kind of
fast cheap and relatively widely
available and so we used a combination
of different imaging electron microscopy
smtm and chromatography so first things
I'll see PI GC XRD spectroscopy like
getting a our elemental analysis a range
of different techniques to really try
and understand the degradation of a bone
material and wood material and so you by
using these complementary techniques we
could get a really good insight into the
breakdown pathways both in organics and
the organics what we were staggered to
see is that for example in the lab based
burial experiments even after one year
the material in the starcast oil was
enormous ly swollen you can see you can
see how degraded it was just within one
year
you got mineral replacement from
hydroxyapatite to gypsum just in that
one year and which we could tell through
the XRD and when we buried and Adeem the
jelly bone as we called it those floppy
bits of bone in microbe reactive soil we
we saw a complete loss within just one
year of this so real incredible rapid
degradation so we break this up for for
PNAS and I've just taken a quote from
that paper and from a chemistry
perspective the tragic deterioration of
the starcast science provides the unique
opportunity to understand our genetic
processes the normally acts are
invisible over research project
but so it was really great for us to be
able to see these ton of rapid
degradation but clearly from a cultural
heritage perspective that duration is
irreplaceable is an irreplaceable loss a
unique archaeological environmental
evidence what was really important to
understand is that actually there wasn't
one solution for how to save the site
they're different mitigation strategies
required for the different materials if
you wanted to preserve you know the
amazing would you needed to to have a
different strategy to if you wanted to
preserve the amazing but and but what's
really great about this project I think
is that we've moved on the lessons that
we've learned from Starke our project
have been used now in curses and
knowledge exchange fellowship and in
conjunction with historic England who
are the people who have responsibility
for looking after heritage sites in the
UK and to basically say help us
understand how we can best safeguard
other wetland sites at risk from
environmental changes across the globe
and so we're really hoping that this
work you know although it's disastrous
for the starcast site itself and it will
actually have a much wider impact in
helping us understand and and mitigate
archaeological loss so that's been a bit
of a whistle-stop tour through all sorts
of different types of samples and types
of analyses and types material and I
think the challenging matrices that I've
been working with it's really personally
anyone doing analytical science
pertinent forensics is potent biologic
it helps us understand what data to
trust and what not to and this kind of
multi analytical complementary approach
is has been essential to understand you
know not just the organic parts but the
inorganic parts of the materials that
we're looking at and of course that
brings its challenges of how best to
integrate these complex datasets
understanding degradation stability and
not just on the analytical side but also
the metabolic side we see it's real
insights and I think one of the areas
that we're expanding into is that min
were organic interface how fascinating
it is and how we can understand how
organisms bio mineralized far better
and and collaboration has been
absolutely critical this works very
closely with lots of different
archaeologists earth scientists
biologists climate scientists and it's
opened up wonderful new world of
discovery so I just want to thank these
who are main contributors to this work
and thank you for Europe and thank you
to all the funders he's and he helped us
carry this out and thank you for your
attention
thank you dr. Pinkman for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left to your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the scene and our speaker
will follow up with your questions via
email so let's get started our first
question is when you isolate the closed
systems of proteins you said the only
time and temperature effect the rates of
the protein breakdown what effect does
this have on your dating work yes so so
obviously it's a chemical reaction so
it's going to be dictated by time which
is obviously the thing that we're
interested in but also the temperature
and so it means that a sample that
sitting in the UK is gonna be maximizing
at a different rate to sample this
sitting in Equatorial Africa and so
obviously we have to take account of
that in our dating and so what we need
to do is when we're building out dating
frameworks we have to build them for a
region that has a similar temperature
history now these regions are actually
pretty large so for example from the
tests that we've been doing the
particular rasterizing in Britain are
doing exactly the same rasterizing the
same rates in the middle of Germany so
you know it could be a region that is
you know on the order of you know a
thousand kilometers where we basically
build that what's called as an amino
stratigraphic frameworks they build a
dating framework and then you tie that
in to absolute dates using
so yeah temperature does have an impact
and we can account for that now are the
rates of these reactions the same for
different species no so the ordering of
the amino acids along the protein chain
is obviously very important for the
rates of the breakdown and we were
seeing that from the egg timer project
and so because a different it you know
each well each genus will have different
proteins to make their shells or their
excel and all their corals skeleton and
then actually they will break down at
different rates and and what one thing
we've been doing is kind of tracking how
different general breakdown and that's
giving us an insight into the processes
but yeah you wouldn't be able to for
example compare an eggshell directly
with a with a gastropod shell you would
have to test how that sample how they
break down and you wouldn't be able to
compare the data directly across between
this but you can build up dating
frameworks using multiple different
species now dr. ping bennett looks like
we have time for one more question how
come your results help protect sites
like stark are so i think one of the
things that staggered me the most was
how little information we had about the
way that sample the way that material
degrades in those very first few stages
and and and so the the the stark our
project has helped us get that data for
important materials like Bonin and wood
obviously you know we're extending that
to other types of materials like leather
and seeds and but but yeah at least
we've got that information for two of
the most archaeologically relevant
materials and and then and through
working with partners historic England
and some of the archeological trusts and
by basically trying to put mechanisms in
place that enable those changes to be
picked up on the short scale will then
mean that we'll be able to identify
sites that are at risk there's a policy
a global policy and these days of
keeping archeologic archeology in cities
so if an archaeological site is
discovered then the policy is to maybe
excavate a very small part of it but
actually to leave most of it unexcavated
and because if you do that and then you
know in 50 or hundred years time other
archaeologists can come with better
techniques with better with better
methods that can then excavate it and
therefore a couple more information so
it's a very it's a very kind of
ingrained policy for the last 20 years
or so or what's called in situ
preservation preserving it in in the
ground where it is originally up now
that's a great policy except where it's
not safe in City and so if for example
that particular region get undergoes
three changes in water table due to
environmental change and that could be
you know climate driven it could be it
could be driven by human activity in the
environment then suddenly that
assumption that the site will be safe
forever in the ground is not valid and
so we're working very carefully with
these with archaeological scientists to
try and make sure that that we can work
out when change is happening and
therefore whether how valid it is for
each individual site to stay preserved
in City and to be able to put in a plan
of action when it's not possible to
preserve that site and sits you anymore
you know whether that's recovery or
whether that's just giving up on that
particular site and so I'm hoping that
this data is it goes in at some small
way towards better preservation of those
types of a very important archives of
our of our history I would like to once
again think doctor Pinkman for her
presentation I would also like to think
Labatt's from making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through January of 2019 you will receive
an email from laberd's letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
Sven's that's all for now thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon goodbye